it is leaked that Donald Trump had a
second undisclosed meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin at the g20
meeting in Germany earlier this month he
had that meeting with Putin with no
American translator more on that later
that's an important part of the story
also an interesting part of the story is
that Trump is reportedly furiously
raging about the fact that news of this
meeting leaked let's get the fake news
defenses out of the way early I mean
Trump will still say it's fake news but
the White House has already confirmed
this once it leaked they said initially
that it was a brief meeting we later
found out from a senior White House
official that it wasn't a brief meeting
it was a nearly hour-long undisclosed
meeting and I mentioned that Trump had
no American translator for the meeting I
don't mean Trump spoke Russian with
Putin obviously that's not what I mean
what I mean is that Trump and Putin both
communicated through Vladimir Putin's
translator which is considered to be a
pretty serious breach of diplomatic
protocol and by the way it's not totally
necessary Vladimir Putin does speak
English pretty well here's proofing in
case you don't believe me
Putin could speak English with Trump if
you wanted to I think no I hope so all
of us - we need separation in some areas
so we said about it during this hour
folks yeah okay so not the best English
but clearly if this was just an informal
meeting Vladimir Putin could have spoken
with Trump in English and no instead we
have Donald Trump in a meeting that was
not disclosed from which we have no
readout like we have in terms of what
was discussed at the official Trump
Putin meeting where Donald Trump was
speaking through a Russian translator
which is a known thing where you can use
unnecessary translators as you could
basically put an intelligence officer in
there as an unnecessary translator and
now you've got a situation where Donald
Trump held an off-the-record meeting
with not only Vladimir Putin but also
with someone who was arguably there
posing as a translator like he
translated but a potential intelligence
officer as well
their excuse of this is that they didn't
have an American translator who spoke
Russian right daddy what happenes
speaking translate yeah which makes it
seems as if this was not something that
was planned out and was just supposed to
be a surprise to everyone into her not
told to anyone else well the White House
has aggressively been going with nothing
to see here everybody does it they said
it is not nearly perfectly normal it's
part of a president duties to interact
with world leaders Trump is furious he
took the Twitter he called the reports
sick tweeting fake news story of secret
dinner with Putin is quote sick I don't
know why he had to put the quotes in
there but he does all g20 leaders and
spouses were invited by the Chancellor
of Germany press new this is hugely
relevant given the nature of the meeting
and no American translator there's no
readout of what was discussed like we
have from the first the official Trump
meeting with Putin Donald Trump might
not even know what was said he was
relying on a Russian translator and John
Kirby who's a CNN diplomatic and
military analyst said quote while
smaller pull-aside meetings are common
it is strange that a pull aside with
someone like Putin especially Putin
would not include at least another
national security officer and a
translator and the assertion from the
White House that this was perfectly
reasonable and normal at the time also
isn't true because we've heard from Ian
Bremmer Ian Bremmer is president of a
geopolitical risk firm called the
Eurasia group he said other people in
the room were shocked by what was going
on quote pretty much everyone at the
dinner thought this was really weird
that here is the President of the United
States who clearly wants to display that
he has a better relationship personally
with President Putin than any of us or
simply doesn't care
they were flummoxed they were confused
and they were startled this certainly
isn't the behavior of an innocent person
- you know with all this attention and
hysteria around the Russia story you
think that he would get ahead of it by
letting the media know by getting an
American translator in that room by
maybe even getting a national security
adviser and in that room with him yeah
it just goes to this idea that and then
the information gets leaked - yet again
they can't learn they're less
and then he's furious and of course the
focus becomes the leaks rather than the
content in the last 24 hours the 8th
person at that meeting in Trump Tower
was identified as a possible Russian
money launderer the Republican health
care bill collapsed the Republican
threat to just repeal Obamacare has
collapsed and also we've learned about
an undisclosed meeting from between
Vladimir Putin and Donald Trump it is
hard to keep up with the news at this
point the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership